good morning everyone welcome back to
GameSpot live I'm here with David today
say what's up David what's up man we are
playing our game of the year this year
whopped yeah I was gonna say I was
saying today he's David and I'm Richard
so this is we're swapping our roles
people do be confusing us anyway so why
not today I am David and we are playing
our game of the year yes zero shadows
diet why yes my man David here is gonna
play all loaded up with the New Game+ so
we don't scrub out here New Game+ like
time sports times form like they stacked
like that after you beat it a few times
you use or how what do you mean by that
well kind of I mean like you just you
you keep raising your your vitality and
all that stuff really only goes up
through one playthrough but like there
might be different bosses that you can
fight on a separate playthrough uh-huh
so you might only get up to like 15
bonus you know low vitality from each
boss but then on the second you know new
game+ with the third new game+ we need
be a different boss you end up getting
that like a little extra boost to both
Lowrey attack power and sub so that's
perfect let's jump into with me yeah
yeah starting at the under bridge valley
so this is the fourth playthrough here
and it's actually paused here because I
thought it's a great place to start
because it's north on and we might die
right away because this is Sakura after
all we will be dying absolutely what's
up chat Brandon already in the chat play
roblox no bro we're not gonna be playing
roblox today I feel like we get that
request like hmm once or twice a week me
from the same guy roblox all the way oh
yeah that should have been our game of
the year ray alright can we hear the
audio okay maybe turn this up a little
yeah you're gonna start hearing some
[ __ ] cool I just didn't know if it was
one of those like silent games until
action starts you know kinda jarring
like that
yeah yeah you might want to turn it out
that's the started off for you guys
that's yeah that's a little flavor that
that's the scheming initial going happy
Friday everyone I forgot to mention hell
yeah that's Friday all right now good
start for real yeah yeah that was just
we were just fooling around right David
well yeah well also cuz you need this
and for this part of the campaign you
have to die at least once for the to do
the Dragon Rock oh you're just playing
the story then let's just Canyon right
there you have to die for those of you
who haven't already played through
second row this is like one of those
components like if you played
blood-borne you end up having to die at
least once to kind of get the narrative
forward here I see the sculpture so cool
it's cheeks I delete old scene just a
little there yeah see he's got the rod
SS
so here's what we're gonna do I'm gonna
run to back to the under bridge Valley
mm-hmm then I'm gonna do something
really uh it's a little funny that I
just thought I just notice he's took a
nice seat there from the fire
Jamal on the chat says still no DLC
shake my head you don't need you know
not for not for this let us know in the
chat if you guys been playing this did
you finish this this year is it your
game of the year let us know alright so
you saved there I'm just gonna quit real
quick because I'm gonna change the
language cuz I don't know if you guys
noticed if what language the sculptor
was speaking in did you I didn't catch
it if check and guess what language the
sculptor was speaking in because it
wasn't it wasn't a Japanese or English
no yeah it's it's a every playthrough
I've been using a different language to
hear it was German they have so many
options yeah they do it's like French
Italian like everything we got so much
whoa it's super fun dude all the voice
actors for uh for sec euro they're so
good the English voice actors great the
Japanese voice actors great to hear
that's like that's like a detail a good
detail and like I don't know gloat about
no for sure
alright snake boy steak boy oh man this
XR and the chat says love it hope you
are tuned in hope you're ready man cause
uh I don't know I haven't played through
this game yet but my man David here he
has
oh boy mr. big red in the chat says
Resident Evil 2 with sin game of the air
hell yeah nothing wrong with that did
you play this week I forget David if
you'd like horror games or not ah
defense depends did you did you try
Resident Evil like demo or anything no
but I did cut the gameplay for it but I
do want to play Resident Evil 2 I own
Resident Evil 2 like I bought it when I
was on sale
and and it's pretty cool nice you can
hear you can smell fear David be careful
the Wayfarer family in the chat says
this is exactly the place I am right now
my second playthrough definitely game of
the year for me
very cool happy to have you here thank
you for joining us on this Friday can
play second row which was our game of
the year that's why we're plenty
let me know in the chat was is this too
loud should be fine
there more than one this guy's
everywhere it's just one I was talking
to chat yesterday and I brought up how I
did want to get into this and I might
just jump into it but I did want to
appreciate it by playing all the
previous games that are similarly demon
souls blood-borne all those Dark Souls I
haven't played a single one and I feel
like I wouldn't be doing this game
justice if I had him but who knows I
might just jump in make my own opinion
from the scratch you know have you
played all of those games David all the
I'm only spiritual I just wanna die I'm
just gonna cool big deal yeah I'd
probably be the same way
we do thanks Oh yesterday when you play
GTA that was too funny appreciate you
here
once again thanks for coming back having
played old game but I am oh okay
I hate this dude it's so tense
listen Harry Potter here here
David I'm so glad you're here this is a
big note for me this is no PE okay so
that's done maybe David can answer this
later but in the chat wafer says I've
seen your review but tell me what's so
great about it for you guys for a second
yeah I haven't played it so David kid
for sure which answer that one um so the
thing about Secura
is there's I mean there's a really hyper
competitive community with from software
games sometimes that I don't want to say
the gate key or that they look down but
there is this sort of thing about you
know get good right right in if you
don't get good then you're just like
your fault yeah you're like a lesser
game or something and I don't I
personally don't believe that and I've
beaten the game I've beaten the game
multiple times so I am fairly okay at
Secura
but at the same time despite me thinking
that gaming is for everyone and
believing in easier game modes and stuff
the one thing that Sakura did do for me
is through sheer like persistency or
through consistency in like prezerv
errands I was able to beat a game that I
was ready to drop in throw away more
times right you're ready to give up I
was ready to give up so many times you
have no idea and yet the game kind of
encouraged me to still kind of look it's
not cheesy but to look within myself and
find something that I even know I had
right and and I appreciate the game for
for pointing that out in me that I that
I am able to do this and I am able to
kind of persevere with these difficult
games so it's great like in our
deliberations a lot of people have the
same sentiment like I look I had to look
deep into myself to find like you know
yeah that flame to keep going but in the
end it was worth it you included you
told us that there was nothing quite
like finishing this game and how you
were left like you know completely shook
birthday
Oh No yeah that was absolutely like an
experience for sure that's great
Keenan and Chad said this game made me
pop some nerves we pried off this his
new game plug yeah this is like my third
new game that's Chan and the chat was
asking yes this is art yeah for sure
yeah you can tell cuz like the health
bar is way higher than it would normally
be at this oh okay okay
cr7 in the chat hey guys what's up
thanks for joining us today this is our
game of the year David on the six I have
I would not hang with this game I'd have
to I'd need the I have no experience
with it so we David is here today thank
goodness I mean I don't have to kill
these guys it could be fun
because the boss is gonna be over on
that other side of the hill they're the
same snake that you poked his eye out
know that snake is gone there's a
different snake you can actually like be
later in the game uh-huh
but that guy's done for now huh yeah we
were eavesdropping there and and they'd
actually talk about the boss so it's
like who's I here we go though that's
cool yeah with a demon right so there's
gossiping yeah it's probably helpful
right yeah yeah they do that a lot it's
anyway who Jamal in the chat says the
feeling of accomplishment from Sakura is
unprecedented
that's how David tried yeah I hung it up
yep Conner that's me it says I gotta
play this but I'm scared do we have
David here today cuz just gonna skip
through this door I couldn't do it not
for stream anyway I would need a lot of
time all right let's see so firecrackers
actually the firecrackers work very well
kind of like blind your enemy or
distract them kinda it's more like a
like a yeah actually you're right
actually blinding would work for the in
that case um I think there's so many
tools for gyobu though it's because he's
on a horse so those firecrackers like
kind of stunned the horse a little bit
right okay it's really good for like
kind of beasts and animals and things
like that and you're saying this guy is
around the corner like oh you about to
fight him yeah he's not just around the
corner you guys are about to see what he
what he does so this is gonna be fun I
just want to make sure cuz I'm probably
gonna die so let me go set up get get
the load out man Connor says I've been
wondering well what will be better this
or go so sushi yeah well it's about to
see huh that's a good question uh all
right let's go to go no no I want to
climb back in your sleep
are you guys ready are we were out I
think we're ready let's do this yeah
dude this looks intimidating already it
is I don't remember the strap for this
I'm just like Oh
whoa poor horse
please bad horse
[Music]
whoa
randal the chat says what's up guys
thanks for een I'm watching Ellie
hell yeah it's that time of year elf is
one of the best Christmas movies
[Music]
Connor I can't publish that but yeah
definitely yeah and this is a
considerably small boss I imagine but
I'm ready freaking out he's The Fairly
main boss he's not looking mini-boss
benching but he's an early stage boss
okay
[Music]
Iron Mike in the chat says tragic effect
of what does a tax session
the checks out
and I'm freaking out just watching David
is in the zone y'all
[Music]
we praveen in the chat asked after the
success of secular will it get its
well-deserved sequel
right I miss you I know but before they
do a second row seat pool they got to do
a blood-borne singles so that's what the
fans want it's probably been fainting
requests for years huh I'm sure yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yep exactly what Ford said hopefully we
get blood going to first oh your life
Brandon appreciates you and checked out
the podcast today and he said he enjoyed
it
oh my goodness
that which the horse is like Brophy
nice dude cleared it thank you
even at the shinobi execution dang Oh
Elden ring will be epic - says Ford
Alden really is gonna be pretty cool I
have no idea what to expect though but
yeah should I just play this game of the
year for a reason yeah sure maybe over
break you know
it's just out of my first-person shooter
you know comfort zone or sure no I know
what you mean but you know what back in
the day I'm getting a lot of the 10 shoe
vibes from a ps1 mm-hmm-hmm the
grappling hook attaches live I love that
game
Daniel and the chasis excellent game
tech euro is the best game of the year
it throws up some emojis we agree it's
our game of the year that was fun being
part of the hole of deliberation it was
a fun day
deciding narrowing it down sure this is
beautiful game this yeah hell yeah
absolutely it's very beautiful and are
some more I think probably had the most
impassioned things to say about the game
and why oh the game of the year and
everything from beyond just like the art
style to but like the way the combat is
kind of like poetic in a sense with the
sound design the you know complexity
despite you only having one weapon for
those of you in the chat who are Dark
Souls veterans or blood-borne veterans
you know a big part of setting up your
character is the loadout the weapon you
use the type of weapon it is the stats
right yeah and SEC euro completely
removed that because it's just one sword
right like work with what you got
perfect it for sure and yet despite it
being simplified it's still so complex
with the different sort of tools that
you used right on your wrist I can't
even think about them right now the
other prosthetic tools yeah the poetic
tools the combat arts things like that
it's um it's it's kind of a big deal you
know it's really cool Brandon Hernandez
who beat Secor the most times in the
game spot a good question probably Jacob
Decker Dave Klein maybe
and Tony in the New York office I know
for sure those guys have like multiple
playthroughs right well do they Platinum
the game oh crap my god or they a
hundred percent of it so all three of
those guys did this and I I mean oh my
goodness I know Jake personally so it's
not I'm not just biased but like I think
he not only played it the most but he
beated the most first he platinum did I
think like the first week he was on that
grunt oh my god was first week first
week it was unreal is this a long game
it's a it's a pretty long game um and
it's only long because you're gonna die
so many times but we got another boss
coming up right here - is there like a
baby mode that I can start with he just
said no but that was the controversy
people were saying that and they uh
there should have been like a like a
baby mode right I don't know that's part
of the appeal like sick girl get good
Ford says I love from some level design
what the hell is going on
holy fool I'm sorry I'm gonna lock
guys on fire
there was like no setup for that he just
came busting in
and gets get zero asked how many hours
of game remember David like on your have
maintained I remember now too many
little infinite
oh my god
bored in the chat says oh man this damn
bull you remember huh
let us know in the chat would your game
of the year is is it Sakura
Oh
I just noticed his name blazing bull
sounds like a boxer sing in a Raging
Bull yeah the the De Niro movie that's
ready which one is hard to beat Dark
Souls are sick hero which one I think
they're both very hard if I understand
correctly
iron Mikes that sick girl was my game of
the year heck yeah blood stains Star
Wars is my game of the year
the mc5 Resident Evil 2 remake oh yeah
blood-stained
link's awakening a tie between Link's
Awakening devil made cries and Brandon
yeah that's cool a nice variety here
this balls on one man
Brenden also says Nintendo's which had
the best year to me cool
I played a lot of mice which one
what doom came out you wanted to
man is it just back-to-back boss fights
in this game David no okay
like that's not a bad thing but I was
just wondering about the gameplay style
yes
so glad you gave it is here give it up
for David every morning like I said
yesterday y'all would not want to watch
me play this for the first time nope
I want to call the whole chunga's
[Music]
they porch on this
jørgen says to be fair I haven't played
this game it's all about the leveling
system for me say I have not played a
heater
and by
David
Oh
[Music]
poor to the chat ocarina is the go it
was man it was our game of the year 1998
we were there I think for during the
stream my game still holds up so well I
love that game
Snake Plissken to the chat imagine all
the hamburgers you can make out of that
old fiery hole
you don't want this curse beat but yeah
you're right there's a lot that it damn
nice dude oh you can breathe how you
feeling man David are you with us yeah
[Laughter]
Wow even more after the fact they can't
even get a breather I'll easy handle
them quickly you know you're doing
let's move on to the option on Castle
okay this is crazy
gave it how many times did you play it
over sorry how many times did you finish
the story this is the fourth new game+
dang that's cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
Johnny Rodriguez in the chat I'm about
to get this get into this game it looks
legit saying man I have not played
where's our game of the year like I said
for a reason so I want to get into a -
maybe over break Jorgen says hope Zelda
breath awhile - is released next year
that'd be cool of course absolutely
coins imma do it for you F in the chat
for Chung is the ball hey what's up Tony
victuals that's another boss oh but this
guy's a little more of a mini boss he's
not like I don't know he's not
particularly no well he's got to so he's
not a mini boss if they only have one
circle yeah you could count them to be a
mini boss I've got to at least then just
totally virtual what's like the strong
like no no it's always two but okay
there's a couple ways we can do this but
I could move so there's poisoning oh by
far selves easier yes and just take out
at least one of this guys oh and then we
could just pick off the rest should I go
here whoa just for myself you know and
then
Oh No Oh Oh a German well sorry let's go
that you can like come right back to
life that's great
well honey you can always come back no
no it's a special little thing you got a
clipped or something it's well kind of
it's hard to kind of go into all of it
that's cool you don't he'll meet you
it's probably something you have in your
loadout err
it's part of the story okay okay the
whole resurrection thing is like this is
kind of a big part of the of the
narrative there cool alright yeah yeah
so it's but you notice how like on the
bottom left there's the the circles yeah
oh they're they're dashed out for you
they're dashed out because I used the
the resurrection technique oh so now and
he got his thing back so it's worth me
just just resting up and resetting is
every time you rest anybody that you
kill or any damage you do gets reset as
well
okay there so slugger that's a good tip
for tab type thing dang whoo Iron Mike
in the chat says the real final boss is
my favorite must be Noah during the
deliberations everyone's like oh this
was my worst boss this was my worst boss
like they're scattered throughout this
whole game but that last boss sounded
like obviously the worst but not too
as goons
yeah I swore those were like one-shot
kill almost
[Music]
see our in the chat says only moon shall
mix with tension I feel that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
now focus sweets all the ads are gone
now it's 1v1
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you got this dude who we do in the chat
pro load action that's right Espeon
don't forget you have an umbrella huh
oh yeah I don't like to use the umbrella
Oh baby knows what's up
I'm just I mean but you're right I do
have an umbrella but I'm not it's like a
defensive umbrella essentially no yeah
it blocks a lot of good looking out chat
oh man chasing
Papa John tis but a scratch iron mike
says Lord st. menu break a controller
[Music]
but he says it's the most rewarding boss
crazy you guys on the chat finish the
game and just rage quit let me know
[Music]
and again in the deliberation Brewers
choosing him of the year David two more
everyone reflected on how satisfying it
is to parry an attack I see why it's
looking great
I'm not even playing
but I felt that you know
oh nice dude dan let's he'd even lose a
life
the guards earlier but like with that
one-on-one fight on the yeah for sure
alright ABG says I rage quit mm-hmm
halfway there started a week ago says
Praveen okay you were you had those rage
quit almost moments in yeah absolutely
um so I don't I mean god I'm just
running into boss fighting the boss
fight fine man I mean they're well no
because the these games are so
open-ended that you can go there's
multiple paths you can take right so I'm
like trying to debate which path to take
whatever feels right may want to like go
through dungeon for what a battle
Genichiro Oh things although this this
section is a little annoying at first
because you're going against the the
nightjars which will we'll see one soon
they're basically these like owl looking
things that buildings and they're like
Molin areas yeah who's one right there
you Sam yeah those guys are annoying AF
he just evade them and like not F with
them trying to have kinda I mean you can
you can't sell through a big part of the
game but the majority of them are going
to see you like that guy right there oh
but that that kite yeah there's a guy on
it I don't know if you can see it
there's a dude like on the boss guy no
just no enemy he's just a guy he's just
you know oh he's like he's like
clutching on the kite and the reason why
is because he's gonna kamikaze you okay
you get closer oh good the first time
the first time that happened there's two
of them you see there's one there and
then there's homie
although I wonder if I I mean I hate
wasting my spirit emblems for this but
we might have to try it out we've got an
hour left man I mean none of these not
about it's not about the time it's about
the using the spirit emblems because it
costs spared emblems every time you use
a skill oh ok so that that's the games
like way of I've encouraged you not to
just like be cheap oh hey whoa dude well
got him
oh yeah well he saw me anywhere but I
noticed you didn't have many of those
spirit things um yeah that guy would
just post it up he'd even see you I was
actually he's not gonna chase me so I
just gotta oh he's gonna fight you from
the farm yeah
[Music]
I almost got the one guy if I am if I
stabbed him to death
hi there I love that he's like where you
going because you can actually feel up
now school
[Music]
got him
so what's the watch you look so
unassuming yeah I didn't see him until
yeah oh shoot J the player hey welcome
to the chat weapon to the screen thanks
for joining little SEC euro a little
game of the year playing today
you guys ready for the weekend okay so
those guys are done there's more I think
those guys oh yeah there's one there's
one there there's one there over on the
other roof
do you have to defeat him or just helps
it helps okay um it does help it helps
both it's like getting your experience
yeah it helps me getting send just the
currency Oh yep it also helps if if
you're a little low on health and you
have the skill where you heal on
deathblows you know it's I think all
good things
there's another one of those kite guys
okay alright so there was only one yeah
there's one patrolling down there
there's this guy here that's good they
don't see ya
well they don't see me yet uh-huh you're
hey get that stealth kill what's up op
gaming Opie gaming is hey guys nice oh
no God you got it Oh Laurie and says I
love how from software makes different
games from all developers
[Music]
[Music]
who all that building saved your life
that things trying to curve around if he
did there you go oh man
the fire guys are actually a little
little gnarlier cold that was cool yeah
they look like a cool combo oh yeah not
all of them have the fire huh
oh you're making short work of these
guys great dude oh I love how you can
grapple items man you've taken out like
ten of these guys army man
yeah all right so we got that guy coming
up soon all right do your thing man yeah
come on bring it
what do I live dude right there - Oh on
the window yeah well just right there
yeah oh shoot around the corner yeah I
did not swell I'm just gonna go in here
sucks this up
do they come inside are they hang out
okay faded yeah you fought enough for
them all right
so you know rest here unlocked another
sculptors Idol ooh
rest up yeah these like save points or
they can be safe points yeah um although
I think you can technically save
anywhere you just have to hit quit game
because the game autosave is so much oh
okay that's good but these guys suck the
guys I'm about to sneak up on they fight
to oh they're regular ass humans no I
mean they are regular ass [ __ ]
regular Avadh Sam happy holidays
GameSpot and chat oh thanks for joining
us happy Holidays to you too
we are wrapping it up here in the
offices taser I heard if you put out
your sword and open flame you will catch
on fire to fire damage I have not heard
this zero you lying I haven't heard that
either but I know jack [ __ ] about this
game sounds fun though yeah that would
be cool okay it's an elderly man that's
a woman
Oh
sorry made some money she probably would
have thrown hands so here's something
cool you want to see something yeah I
want to possess this guy he'll just kill
me possess him so it costs a lot of
spirit emblems what's let's see the
damage well I mean he just works
Oh for you that's it ik is about a wreck
these guys oh that's cool he'd do that
with like a massive enemies oh my gosh
all right I'll help you out
all right did they have good HP when you
do that I mean oh yeah I mean you keep
like okay
look he cleaned up Oh No
thanks for your help after all that yeah
your work is done
so are you yeah anytime anytime if you
guys see there's kind of like those
banners that hang over a door you could
you could like bug against it and it'll
it'll move some goodies inside ah sick
all right we are almost at probably one
of the main big boss fights and I think
this is like the true test for people
who just start SEC Euro like if you're
gonna be okay with it or if you're gonna
man or if you're gonna like hate
yourself this will like make or break
you it's like I look scrawny fighting
[Music]
oh not cool not cool guys that's right I
think both will wait for them to walk
away yeah Shh good job guys yeah yeah we
got him
psych jeez I thought this was the
weakest guy that's Ronnie dude they're
not they're not we that was some good
sound work though I liked all the
clanging around all the deflecting yeah
that's cool
maybe this is just the father gascoigne
of the game yeah and Ichiro could be oh
yeah I think that's I think that's a
good green
yeah that's a good comparison is there a
practice mode for deflecting is there
any tutorial in there at all okay no
there's a there's a man who is undying
and he wants to die because he hates
being cursed and being undying tells you
hey excuse me for short practice oh
shoot like if you kill me it's cool you
can practice your executions or whatever
because he kind of has this desire to
that's cool they it's helpful it's
pretty little help
it's it's pretty cool I'm not gonna lie
that was a very clever way to say use
sort of like a the dragon rock hurts all
these different things
love that grappling hook yeah grappling
hook is great that's what reminded me of
tint you of the most mmm
except of course so much smoother
see yeah that's dope
[Music]
chill yep thank you chill for a sec read
up on chat everyone up guys yeah
have everyone calmed down and down
they're all right they're gonna look
around think that they know some [ __ ]
but they don't
yeah someone's dead but we'll just worry
about it later well that guys on the D
he's on he's ready to fight you can also
tell by the music cues right if you're
like in any sort of danger yeah I'm sure
yeah one of these guys again
[Music]
night
I was in a ruckus yeah we're gonna open
this door cuz it's like a mini
checkpoint mm-hmm
it just makes it so if we die in the
next couple seconds getting here is
gonna be a lot easier and then you could
go past these guys and go through a
hallway you'll end up on a little house
around the time where you'll discover a
sheen mm-hmm who said Oh boss are
helpful character my Manolos depending
on your choices in the game
really yeah so it's a good time
whoo Isaiah says resonable two games the
year 2013 it's a good one great one I
couldn't wait for that all right here we
go let's see if we can be kidney trio
you need rose actually no joke - oh well
this guy first
oh he's post-op he's like I've been
expecting you although he um he's got a
weakness I think it's
[Music]
all right come on this whoa
oh that took so much oh oh yeah
I hate that wrecking his furniture
[Laughter]
what timing dude yeah
area about
[ __ ] he just bounced on his head
whoa oh that was sick he's gone
now he's got one that's sick
jørgen says next year is gonna be a good
game year oh yeah there's a lot to look
forward to the 20-point weight came back
I was looking at the chat No
Oh God him my god alright that's how you
do it folks that's it's like what we had
two mini bosses one big boss three mini
bosses one big boss all those dumb
Howell guys and it's like skn once the
umbrella hey guys I'm so sorry I sucked
it with the umbrella I just can't get it
right so I just deal with uh what the
poison bleep and set out and it and it
worked so we're gonna stick with that
alright time for genichiro which oh I've
heard that name around the office yeah
yeah well I'm gonna die oh I like I need
it it's just a matter from here no oh
yeah yes no no oh boy here we go
is this it is it this is it um I don't
remember what can eat your Oh does if
anything my the cheap thing that I do is
like I used the Phantom kunai which like
will take away some health sometimes and
and a desperation mode I'll just like
waste all of that and just take like a
quarter of their health or a third of
their health and just like use that as a
launching point mmm kind of starts to
fight and I really don't remember what
to use here maybe if someone really
wants the umbrella I'll I'll use the
[ __ ] number uh whatever you're
comfortable with no cuz like cuz nothing
else is really gonna work okay you hold
our tuition
let's see pravin in the chat there we go
yes it's here it comes
yeah here comes Sam that boy that feel
in the chat next year will be a great
year for Pizza fans okay yeah I'm not
gonna say no to that
every year is a great year for that all
right let's do it for the record I've
been beating all the other [ __ ] so
if I could stuck on this for the next
hour you know you don't blame me right
this is the kind of game it is man he
not you thought they would I didn't know
so cars are stressing me out
boy
pushing OGG Theora Thomas Siddiki
Messina Goethe wrote Oh de nada
todo esto todavía boruto
he not your touch are you cannot Tony
Matos syringa raagas Shino be naughty
Jerkins are called open him yeah I can I
can see that
Oh mcclenney son Joey Toshi much done
Praveen says this box the value of a
Perry your eyes Kareem every boss knows
but yeah sure oh dear all right cute
uncut
doing well continue at the community
sucks here we go
that freaked me out more than just a
bombardment all right all good
guru saw get know
got no jobs already
[Music]
[Music]
can imagine your health bar so much
smaller like your first playthrough it's
much smaller like in no way oh my god
[Music]
wall
[Music]
haha
told you do to come all screaming back
to you whoa
[Music]
Oh
it's alright it's alright good that feel
says from ajan from software coming up
absorb boiled peanuts you know your
footing didn't work so now this is gonna
be this movie I know it's it's totally
fine the the only thing the hardest part
was pretty much already done it's great
you know it's gonna it was almost out
did I don't got this we got this we got
this let me swap this and go back to and
we'll be we'll be fine yeah so many many
items yeah you do get a lot of them for
sure for sure okay we're good here we go
we're good we're good
David's in the zone look alive dude this
thing is like it's like if you want an
adrenaline rush just play a boss it's so
good
alright I just go man I'm trying to
chill over Christmas break and I have a
heart attack but all these game looks go
the hardest part for a lot of people too
is the Meharry counters which is like
probably the one thing that I'm actually
laughter that right there oh there's
nothing on the thing a lot of people my
opposition isn't like we're saying they
were having a tough time with that and
these guys are like way better than he
had other games you know liked a taste
so better than most but even he was like
I can't oh and I'm like I'm hitting
everyone pediments nice it's all good we
are playing on xbox 1x today
jordan says eldering a new souls game
and then maybe blood-borne just all of
it right Bolin chat says this guy's cook
has three phases took me two months to
beat him yep oh he does that big face
all right okay
now we got a face to see where he gets a
little more aggressive Oh God right from
right out of the gate
[Music]
Sakura welcome welcome to the chat
welcome to the stream gar-bear why don't
we clean borderlands 3 they were playing
our game of the year wait always someone
said yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh nope Ford says last box
last box took me eight straight hours
wearing it out we're hearing a lot of
that is crazy
nice I like that move bouncing on him
hole we're gonna have to get back to you
he says the guy who's playing she's
really good at this any tips on how to
beat the Guardian eight we will come
back to that yeah
David is in the zone he's on plane we'll
take that question later I can't speak
on that I actually haven't
[Music]
alright alright I didn't I'm gonna lock
in all right it's this part it's about
to get this third form is third form
it's gonna get rid of get brutal okay oh
there's even there's even a cutscene in
kenosha nope you remember you have items
to get back yes I do
I do thank you Ken yeah thank you for
that reminder thought it was show could
some what do you wanna do this yeah dude
imagine imagine you're playing this for
like six hours or three hours trying to
like beat this guy and then this happens
and you're just like I don't even know
it's about I'm freaking out
crush and I'm not even clean I'm
watching it's so
[Music]
have to be you guys
[Music]
okay I don't I really don't remember all
of his moves I just remember when he
tries to hit me with lightning I need
light umph up take the lightning either
throw it back at him you have to ride
the lightning oh my god yeah this won't
say that yeah oh no I just secured those
you okay here we go the armor is
straight up
you got this David oh you missed ya
okay well he missed that was a really
bad time pretty feel though jump
all my diamonds music
no back in it back in it
[Music]
skn is with it he's like man I love this
game so much height here we go
Hey gonna bet their own do I really have
to pee it freaked me out
No
all right that's all right okay that's
okay that was a great first attempt are
you back up yes
[Music]
my heart rate
got him there you go yes dump spam the
chat with dubs guys to do okay
now you did it do nice I don't have to
go in Peter thank you I'm just watching
- I'm bear it back y'all let's go
oh my lightening says alright but yeah
just chill and enjoy this cutscene era
thoughts the more you re musta mechonis
Genovia Thank You Chad thank you thank
you Gigi's all you guys man Thank You
Jimmy whoo
yeah it's hard you know I'm like I'm
trying to like walk in and I think you
guys are giving me really good advice
and I'm like I don't want to let chat
down you know it's our game of the year
I want to be a good representative of it
so I'm coming but we got more we got hey
man we got 30 more minutes let's see if
I can find another box
maybe someone talked about the headless
ape earlier there's a lot of things you
can do for the headless a guardian APIs
is a different thing but for the
headless Abe for sure use I forgot the
name but it's like the the pedal it's
like this pedal that gives you
experience and it'll work
also he doesn't scream if he used the
the lotus flower' Lotus shield umbrella
lotus flower umbrella
that'll help too so both she'd imagine
he had a fourth face yeah dude for sure
if he had a fourth face I would I would
cry yeah thank you guys I'm dude the
hype is real man everything you guys are
feeling that's that's what's going in my
chest right now I'm like having a mini
heart attack sorry I don't mean to skip
through all the story stuff I just want
to get to the next boss to see what's up
someone wants me to go straight for the
headless state let's see if I can do it
man I got to get to the like the
undertow sunk in underpass I don't know
if we're gonna have time for that but I
can do it
y'all this game also made me piss my
pants we would have streams going on
today I'm leavin plane
god I forgot what choice I'm supposed to
make Oh is there a UH honorable one and
dishonorable one do kind of students
they're gonna make me I feel really I
feel really bad that I'm skipping
through all this for for a chat but like
for what it's worth guys like we already
started halfway through the story and
it's better if you just kind of just see
the action and experience the story for
yourself hell yeah
that's what you're here for right
absolutely Ford apparently not yet any
DLC for this game announced ok so where
do I go next don't my dungeon ah the
game answered your questions yeah
Alabama says wow I need to get this game
immediately heck yeah
oh ok we can do we can do the last phase
we can run through that real quick
there's a mini-boss there too I think
that's oh no no there's the UM the lady
butterfly we guys we can get to the yeah
hopefully we can get to there we go a
little over if need be yeah yeah maybe I
think you should be fun cuz Lady
butterflies another really good early
boss oh cool yeah sounds cool ok I'm
picturing an actual butterfly no dude I
thought we do when we first got the game
and we were playing it and everyone was
talking about it in chat and slack chat
in our work chat and being like oh I
just finally met lady butterfly it's
like no what is that so
okay so this is actually a past memory
that we're in okay just play it right
I'm so play I got a plane dude I'm so
glad we gave this our game of the year
cuz there's a lot of great games were
okay as Cain is like yep
we better fly let's do it he's in I will
say it really does help that I have
these like skills and items unlocked and
you know what I mean for all of you guys
who who play through this and bikini
trio like the first time like it's so
much harder cuz you don't have nearly as
much health work like you had you'd
imagine playing on your first
playthrough with a little help far in
zero items yeah I don't know but you did
it you had to do it to get to here when
you are down I'm sure it's a crabber
yeah
Oh God
oh great calling the squad upgrade your
attack power is this from software's
first game of the year game I think so
what about the double check that
Alabama tick says your stream inspires
me I just got it can't wait till it down
bro we made a sale here enjoy that's
great
enjoy the frustration and the bring your
controller but also also ensure that you
David for sure hey man that's I'm glad
to hear it I hope you enjoy the game
said it before I'll say it again it's
our game of the year for a reason
absolutely and like I'm sold to we're
handing it over to David cuz he knows
what he's doing
I have not played now I'm ready to
fat drunk boy killed me so many times oh
yeah yeah like borracho from
what's-his-name Mortal Kombat although I
don't remember what prosthetics for him
are like super effective every boss
sounds so unique with like like you
really there's so many different
fighting styles Oh
[Music]
Billy in the chat says I would advise
you to eavesdrop on Emma the sculptor to
get the owl's bill fight him at the
errata yeah it's it's an ending and
actually it's the last ending that you
know what's up well I
oh man the dogs the wolf
jørgen this game needs a mod that gives
the jump a Mario sound let's open let's
open this door just in case
are you still within this memory yeah
yeah yeah we haven't got any time when
it's like oh ye drop knock hilum
okay these guys needs a the oh these
guards coming up the actually chopped up
their shield there's a wooden shield
it's really thank you try to like go by
their shields without it
alright so there's one boss here
[Music]
Alabama yep this game looks so brutally
good you will experience it soon
downloading it today right this game is
sexier Oh says the bra guy
I'm surprised I haven't heard that yet
Ford says yeah the games are amazing
actually challenging like old school
Oh Oh
oh shoot as he shoots an arrow
another that
dude arrow guys were a problem even in
tension now I'm thinking of that in the
middle of a fight you get hit with an
arrow from the guy from the bar on xrs
how many hours did you guys spend on the
final boss I spend I spend a lot
I spend multiple weeks my god
oh stop - this guy these guys
[Music]
there you go if this guy Booker asks
happy to get that or a hit the blue or
the blue is something that is is that a
good thing a more powerful hit oh it
looks like it basically you have to
upgrade your actress to get to that
level the any move like lapis lazuli
allows your right type aura is a final
stage and you get to sorry I got
distracted
oh and BAE that's like the final one
into this whole chat bzi switch final
boss there's two there's three there's
three yeah depending on which ending you
are you get but the main one is a Shinto
sword Saint which is there's two endings
that will give you that boss and that's
the one that's the one that took me
forever oh man
Alabama pinched you on this banking oh
yeah one of my personal favorites
flamin arrow enough of that it's like
you said what yeah boo laughs are you
going or Lady butterfly I think that's
the plan yeah yeah check
oh my goodness there you go it's easy to
get like Kingdom sasuser quick seems
like them ten time that's happened you
with like two guys come out of nowhere
yeah one more we just run past this guy
here oh my god oh my god guys camera was
all up on his blood here we go this is
where the action is it seems oh my god
wow your dad over in a memory
okay so we got to basically get to the
lady butterfly Oh
the fire all the all the the effects
right here in this town looks so good
like it's devastating obviously but it
looks really good it's really good the
river below you if you swim in the
streams there's like a bunch of items
you can find there too protip good to
know but we're also you know just skip
all that for now yeah it's a lady
butterfly
she's got a beat the big fat jump guy
earlier that's right there he is
no one's not here coming up Greg in the
chat says I'm so happy to scott game of
the year I haven't played it but it's my
type of game no I will love playing it
when I pick it up same I'm in the same
boat
[Music]
[ __ ] that axe yeah make short work of
those that sounds great
fighting each other oh I didn't notice
oh yeah yeah they're like screaming
Pizza Chu asked you to swim in this game
yeah yeah you can you can swim you can
dive once you get a certain technique oh
absolutely I mean you could swim
regardless
what's alike dive you have to you have
to get a certain skill okay and on the
bottom of the ocean is where the water
is where all that good stuff is man
there you go rest up chaddy sees this
new game+ yes it definitely is new game+
for sure chad DZ it absolutely is
someone's gonna come out here
yeah
No you know something's up the food that
guy was not suspecting they're just
gonna run by all of these guys although
I would hope chat reminds me what the
trick was for the drunkard I think it's
like oil and fire oh but I can't
remember I mean I might just mean bad
but hopefully someone can confirm its
so now that we're here another pro tip
pro tip I'm gonna get people have beaten
it notice already but like another thing
you can do is there's a lot of people
they're you know I mean a lot of people
there I'm seeing like three or four at
least oh five more guys over there too
so you you have to unfortunately it's a
little tedious but you have to go around
and make quick work of the guys here
these two are no well you pick the side
that's good didn't you know you can go
straight for the middle for sure the
other thing that you can do is if the
boss sees you you can run away far
enough for him to eventually lose sight
so the boss oh yes
if you're on here and you get one by one
one by one there you go he just did
Adrian says I could not get past this
part hopefully he's pro strat beating
through he's gonna follow you there he
is and you just you keep running around
various and just mess up these guys
so it's less stress
it said you're just clearing out the
crew here absolutely
oh god he's right there yes and almost
done with the guards oh great that was
the guys so all the guards are dead Oh
awesome
fiiine says this guy's a jerk oh yeah
I'm about to find out now
essentially good to go so now here's the
other thing
[Music]
buddy I don't want to I don't want to
run into that old guy because he's
actually gonna help you old I yeah okay
okay how far disappeared right yeah he's
out of sight he's on screen Hey okay now
you just go back when you're ready
haha he's gonna stand in the middle
which gives you a great ahh
mantis point to sneak up on them like
start stealth and you do the do the
thing where you take half his health
right away you can do that with bosses
oh yeah you did that early on with that
first me that's sick all right sir just
Adrian says thanks oh god guys huge look
at his sword and now what we do is we
run to this guy here the old man let's
talk to him super quick imma be like hey
look at him
what did you say I miss things they just
what would you say to him like my guy
was talking [ __ ] about your mother like
what so the other thing I think it is
the oil so you're gonna take some oil
and you're gonna quit you should have it
by now
boy the flame that I have a better flame
vent at the moment but plane vent for if
you're new and
nice place
and then you uh coiled up oh my god sent
out his brain and distracted that other
guy is great distraction
Adrian god I wish that I would have
known that before
oh god that sword
Nikki wrote wolf just like that he's
already down and pro strats all right
lady butterfly oh now now it's Lady
butterfly the time yep to close it off
there's some guys lingering around say
Kiro wolf says merry christmas and a
blessed New Year's told to y'all all
y'all oh thanks for joining us today
ok checkpoint we can sick we got we got
some time yeah we do five minutes at
least for a good attempt maybe a little
over if we need to
sorry was that the last part
oh I said maybe we can go a little over
you know maybe aperture get that win I
definitely know we're here though which
is supposed to help you with the boss
okay looks like he tried and failed
pretty much only gave me one I think he
usually gives like three but
well here we go
so with her I mean this is this phantom
cognise actually her weapon but I think
the prosthetic this shuriken is all that
I need for now mm-hmm
hopefully that's all I need for now
maybe I'll use I'll try to use the
umbrella we'll see
don't need the boy alone ok I think this
is a good loadout all right let's do it
this is it we've been talking about this
lady butterfly for like at least an hour
now this is it
oh boy wish I woulda show chef the monk
the foster out where you kill her in 30
seconds
if that's the lady butterfly cuz she
kind of is a monk I don't know but I do
know people who like make short work
with this boss no I don't like this
Jinjin this'll last 30 minutes did you
find the purple assassin good on the
hill no I know who you're talking about
though young he's tough for sure and I
don't know if darks will some use harder
than second row because I've never
played dark same and I've only played
part of Dark Souls 1 and I'm like a
quarter of the way through but I have
gone to the final boss in blood-borne
and I think what's harder than secretary
knows not to chase that girl's not hard
I had a not I had a nightmare
it's like hard harder it's very this
game is extremely difficult especially
towards the end but blood-borne was just
like a different beast for me it was so
tough and frustrating and gratifying
when we finally beat it I'm worried dude
it's always these little unassuming
bosses
so agile
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she has to have more than one former my
right oh whoa
don't like that
[Music]
[Music]
here's a second
it's gonna die the look on top of the
statute okay
yeah boy Oh chilly just appeared yet she
was just watching you the whole time you
told me to look and I still missed it
oh great
[Music]
pour it in the chat anyone else want to
play this again after watching the
stream
oh my god
[Music]
I'd hate projectiles do you see spirits
dude spirits are about to show up right
now yeah I'm gonna use my snap seed
though which I should have a bunch
[Music]
Oh No
odd coif up over gone puffing away
[Music]
that dinky little kick took so much help
ford says i have all of next week off
I'm gonna give it another go
I think I might play over break also XR
for sure says our XR says for sure I
want to reinstall his right
[Music]
[Music]
they're doing great there's a lot of
back-and-forth but you're not getting
dr. Scott
[Music]
[Music]
nice that was for whatever that was
Oh
[Music]
the spirits yeah
what'd you just charge it okay
[Music]
nice
[Music]
SK and says I picked it up a picks back
up after y'all made the game of the Year
announcement
I must platinum it I think David's on
that quest also
[Music]
Evan in the chat
oh [ __ ] is that David enriched plane
Shadowside once maybe twice every you go
what's up
[Music]
do these little spirits know
[Music]
yeah so what that's a
no more forms yeah dude
what a great way to end this dream huh
yeah yeah I'm not gonna pull the plug
yet we killed like we killed that one
weird samurai
blazing pull the drunkard lady butterfly
my god as we damn near just beat like
over a third of the game right there so
man sick David he killed it man so glad
you were able to join me on Street Oh
those of you know what happens to them
now so it's all good well man that'll
that'll that'll wrap it up for us man
let's end on a high note there let me
switch over here absolutely thank you
all for joining us and thank you David
for joining me especially I would have
no idea what to do and now I want to
pick up this game so tune in we will be
back the week after the next 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard time to play some more
stream some more join us in thank you
all for watching and we'll see you next
time enjoy your holidays yes have a good
race everyone in a great new year
we're think this is our last room till
we get back from break writing so yeah
we're gonna be back around January or
maybe I think the 30th of December a
little bit right before new year we'll
be in for like a day or two but for sure
in the New York we'll see you guys in
2020 mmm take care you guys holidays
everyone take care bye
[Music]